et à ce stade bien évidemment si je vous
parle ou ce que terre vous me répondrez
borotra cochet lacoste rognon les héros
de la coupe davis
il y à bien longtemps déjà alors bien
sûr même s'ils ne sont plus que deux ils
ont leur place toujours un roland garros
est depuis aujourd'hui leur place ils
l'ont plus que jamais à la dormance il
ya peut-être une raison utilité à ses
statuts c'est que quand les gens les
verrou ça leur fera peut-être réaliser
ce que la bonne entente entre les
mousquetaires la profonde amitié qu'ils
avaient les uns pour les autres
la coopération entre eux a permis de
réaliser qu'ils pouvaient me incarner
l'amour du tennis jean borotra jacques
brugnon henri cochet rené lacoste
ces quatre tennismen de légende ont
écrit la plus belle page de l'histoire
du tennis france faire baptiser les
quatre mousquetaires ils ont conquis la
coupe davis en 1927
avant de défendre le prestigieux trophée
jusqu'en 1938 les vicissitudes de la vie
ont séparé ces quatre merveilleux
champions jacques brugnon et henri
cochet ans disparue tous seront
désormais immortalisé un stade roland
garros une place à leur nom a été
initiée afin de récompenser l'ensemble
de leur oeuvre des statuts des
représentants réalisé par le sculpteur
italien vito n'diaye ont été érigés pour
souligner l'importance de ces quatre
joueurs dans le monde du tennis philippe
chatrier a déclaré qu'il lui a paru
essentiel que les centaines de milliers
de spectateurs qui viennent du monde
entier célébrait tournoi sachent ce
qu'ils doivent à nous quatre champions
un vibrant hommage aux mousquetaires
sans lesquels le stade roland garros
n'existerait pas
pour mieux se souvenir il trôneront pour
toujours dans le temple du tennis